right that looks pretty good thank you
for agreeing to a selfie stick interview
with us delices go for a walk absolutely
so as you know these are all about
yourself so we want to find out a little
bit about yourself and it's fair to say
that the conservatives here in Scotland
are the underdogs can you give us an
example at the time in your life when
you've been an underdog and I will are
pretty cavalier attitude to personal
safety so I keep breaking myself I've
broken my legs my pelvis my back in
different things so I keep having to end
up in hospital and relearn how to walk
so I guess that's maybe an underdog
thing yeah I'd go with that yeah and and
here in Scotland then and what is it
that makes you really keep fighting for
the Conservatives because you've got an
uphill struggle haven't you well at the
last general election we got over
400,000 nearly 500,000 votes same as the
Liberal Democrats same as the SMP our
problem in Scotland is that we are is
also our great strength or our people
have spread right across the country so
my job is to to focus our campaign to
make sure we get a few more wins on the
boards and people in Scotland see is
winning again and this attitude that
you've got the personal safety and
throwing yourself into the internet a
kind of works with that doesn't it but
you know I've always believed that it's
not the size of the dog in the fight
it's the size of the fight in the dog
and I'm a wee scrapper so I'm happy to
get involved thank you very much thank
you